bonjour youtube propose un service qui
s'appelle les sous titres automatique
ce service existe déjà depuis plusieurs
années sur les vidéos anglaise et vient
tout juste de sortir pour les vidéos
française le principe youtube scan
toutes les voix françaises d'une vidéo
pour créer automatiquement les sous
titres c'est très pratique pour les gens
qui apprennent le français ou les
malentendants pour vous montrer le
résultat je propose d'activer les sous
titres automatique sur la vidéo la plus
vue cyprien répond un cortex et de
refaire les paroles en fonction des sous
titres ça donne ça
données en mémoire toutes les cartes et
plus élevés au monde
bon ben là ya un trou ça commence bien
peut être pas très très important c'est
très bien rappel points contre hanovre
les basketteurs du tiroir caisse mes
collègues de viol sur laëtitia la
légende pour exister et je cette entente
ayant toujours total 19 8 euros dans sa
lettre capitaine de wolfsburg
quand il était enfant doit s'exprimer
vous étiez déjà majeur encore un trou ce
qu'ils apprennent le français se
démerdent pour l'instant réagir à
permettre carrière décolle pas d'impôts
encore un trou ça c'est pour les
malentendants retourne à l'école jules
ferry dans un 10 bonnes pour il veut
absolument me rancourt donné rendez vous
sur les choses
la cuvée 2007 des pickpockets tu fais
partie des qualifiés ma petite idée en
tête
les dessins animés et leur est permise
la vie est une pilule contraceptive en
2030 et le mensonge
j'ai ma grand-mère pour un bien un
talent à cuba en étant reçus
il est vrai qu'il est toujours
officiellement le manoir et pour finir
encore un petit trou ma mère m'a
toujours à faire déplacer sur les
handicaps
comme je le dit si bien la vie est une
pilule contraceptive
au revoir
[Musique]
tu veux voir mes prochaines vidéos alors
cliquer ici à bonoua ma chaîne youtube
sinon retourne à l'école jules ferry
dans un avec les basketteurs du tiroir
caisse